how are you Bruce great okay so why did
the committee do what they did it's a
great question hard to get a straight
answer my best rationale because they
spent so much time talking about how
important is that quality win and how
important it is to encounter
championships
well Alabama didn't do either but also
Alabama didn't lose by 30 plus points to
an unranked Iowa team after they'd
already lost to Oklahoma
so no nice punch on this there's some
people in the committee even if they did
it subconsciously looking oh well we got
Clemson sitting there at the number one
seed and Alabama has given them good
games last year they've been great game
Alabama won one lost one and last year
we saw this matchup and once and just
destroyed Ohio State JD Berra I think
they're more confidence in Alabama right
now even though they didn't want a
conference championship and really oh
I'd say probably has three good wins
that are better than Alabama's best win
which is over a nine in three LSU so
what is Big Ten Commissioner Jim Delaney
saying today what's he thinking you
think what's he thinking I wouldn't be
surprised if this is the kind of thing
that some people in that office going
hey maybe we should have lose this thing
to 18 because this is the second year in
a row their conference champ has been
snubbed and I think that that's tough
you know it's like also obviously the
pac-12 has got left out and so I think
they say well do we do a five five teams
all power five conferences champs get in
and maybe we get one group of five team
spots you have larges there are
obviously more games and more money but
there'd be a challenge logistically to
do that so I'm curious to see if this
thing gets any traction and it builds
from there if it's just frustration at
the moment or if it's actually something
that takes on a lot more weight so who
makes that decision how does that get
going a somebody calls up John skipper
at ESPN or John skipper calls up
somebody at the NCAA or this is brought
up at some president's conference
wherever that happens how does this work
loose well I think if it's gonna if it
sometimes it's gonna have
I think it's going to be driven either
by the SEC Commissioner and the SEC
brass or it's going to be through a
bunch of joining in Big Ten folks I
would say yes he's not going to be
kicked off they gotta do it this year
so take the question of what is the big
head
you don't just joining the big head look
at this you're going you got a big good
system you in flawed you know you're
always going to have somebody
disappointed but this is you know this
is something that we we think is
something that needs to be rectified
because they always tweak key things but
this would be obviously a major fix not
just so do you think he got it right
Bruce you know I would just based on the
logic that they have talked about I
would have thought it would have been
Ohio State just because they talked
about a lot about conference
championships matter and and this
quality win if you had asked me this
dynamic four years ago I would have
thought Alabama would be would have been
higher up because they only have one
loss but they don't they kind of
downplay some degree how much losses
matter compared to quality with no
championship let's be honest Bruce I
mean they'll do that for a few weeks but
when it all comes down to it putting uh
you know brass to you know tax to brass
here they gotta they got to put two
games together the country wants to see
or and watch and it all came down to an
eye test in a smell test
does it look like a a championship team
or not and they saw they saw how City
against Wisconsin they saw Alabama
against Auburn in the Iron Bowl and they
sat back and they're like okay which
game do we want to run back the national
championship game the last two years of
the game they were as a blowout shutout
loss I think in that's the end of it
Bruce right I wonder
yeah Ohio State wins that game Saturday
night thirty five to ten as opposed to
down to the wire I think you've got a
difference you might have got a
different result but Ohio State didn't
look dominant you know they honestly
look dominant I guess your alma mater
Michigan and now they look dominant in
the name we had a couple of weeks before
that against Michigan State but when you
guys a couple of you know one blowout
loss and another one quite honestly well
Oklahoma was clearly the better team and
it was in Columbus I don't think you
have anyone to blame but yourself if
you're it
Ohio State okay now a few minutes left I
have we the Bruce let's talk coaching
searches what can you tell me that's
there happening at Tennessee and now at
Florida State
the Tennessee things of God just so
chaotic in the last week with this
craziness around the Greg Schiano higher
where they hired up and then they know
both sides agree to it and then they
pull back in San Ramon and then it went
off the rails from there Jimbo you know
is are they gonna go for Mike Gundy is
he really gonna take it no of course
he's not easy chip turned it down and
like one guy after another then they get
to Mike Leach the ADEs all set to hire
him like leeches on board and then they
blow up the deal because there's a power
play behind the scenes no former who
would always wanted to be da dee he's
now the ad I don't think he's gonna want
to hire Mike Leach you know from talking
to people around you know the Tennessee
brass one other things I heard today and
I've heard it a couple of times this
weekend was that don't be surprised with
both former gives a long hard look -
Chad Morris a head coach at SMU or Brent
Venables who the defense for dinner
Clemson somebody to guide that Homer
really trusts and we've got our big
believers of both of those guys from
their Clemens a days obviously been a
home is still there so there's that as
far as deaf as you I do believe that
that Willie Taggart who's at Oregon now
former USF coach he is the prime target
there it was reported not that long ago
maybe an hour ago that really Tiger was
finalized a deal to become the next head
coach I can tell you that is not
accurate status no with it nowhere near
that far along I have a good source on
those who said they haven't even met as
of yet so now wouldn't shock me if
Willie Taggart left to take the FSU job
that's home for him and he grew up a
Florida State fan and Bobby Z border
states agree is a great job but keep in
mind he has probably a personal talent
at quarterback at Justin Herbert they
have really done a really good job
building things up and I'm sure until
night like the direction of it and would
like to do whatever he can to try to
keep really fast there well in terms of
the Tennessee job been McAdoo's
available Bruce and I bring that up
completely facetiously - to get to the
David
Shaw situation because there may be no
situation at all I started the show
saying if I'm Tish I'm Mara or any owner
in the NFL my first calls to David Shaw
and saying here's a check what number do
I write knit you come be my guy do you
think that's possible
what David Shaw dot I think it's
possible to reach out I don't think he's
ready to go yet I made it I this comes
with no direct no insight from David
Shaw in the last month or whatever I
just think at some point he's make that
move I just don't think he's ready he
loves it at Stanford he loves like this
the environment he has there it's just a
matter of when does he do it
I mean what year I don't think I I don't
think he would leave right now I really
don't but you know I think if you're the
NFL you gotta call an act and if I'm
talking to a college football writer the
first Monday in December and there's a
New York City scene scape blaring behind
him on the phone that must be his
Heisman time correct Bruce is that
what's going on so who do you expect to
hear tonight what names you expect to
hear tonight tomorrow
this weekend I would expect it to be
Baker they feel that a runaway he may
have the biggest margin of victory that
anyone's ever had in this award it's you
know it's not even close at this point
so but who is your gonna be the early
seeing people getting the invitation in
New York doing know Bruce either know
either Lamar Jackson and or was shot
penny from San Diego State I guess
there's a chance that you could have
take Juan Barkley from Penn State in
there as well but I think really in this
case it's two guys who were on the radar
and one guy so far in front that's Baker
the other guy would be Bryce was asking
the poll question before we go out the
door here Christopher Bruce what's the
best bowl game the one you're most
interested in the Sugar Bowl the Rose
Bowl or the Cotton Bowl which one you're
gonna watch more than if you can only
watch one which one would you watch
Georgia has a great linebacker day bro
Kwan said he's fantastic I can't wait to
see him against the quarterback at
Oklahoma cuz that guy is playing out of
his mind I'm here with a bunch of
college coaches we were also in New York
two guys last night all Xactimate the
best college quarterback Davis
way to play right now Bruce take care of
yourself look both ways before crossing
the street but you already knew that yes
you got it this Bruce Feldman the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience